hey everyone it's Mike from overflows
and welcome back to my channel I'm glad
you could join me for today's video
where I'll be talking about value areas
and quickly before we jump in just make
sure you hit subscribe if you like to
see more videos like this and be sure to
leave your comments because today's
video on value areas
um is there a direct result of several
comments that I got
on earlier videos about uh order flow
and value areas so let's just really
quick take a look at these comments so
as Val says thanks for the content Mike
I appreciate your time any videos
contain new setups or value areas would
be appreciated
uh Henry III asks uh do you have a
percentage for Value area like 60 or 70
percent and uh Nicholas says we want to
see different ways you see value areas
Mike so let's take a look at Value and
you know how you can use it in in your
trading now
just really quickly right um you know
most Traders are familiar with valuaries
because especially order flow Traders
right they they've studied already
Market profile volume profile now the
inventor of Market profile uh Peter
stottlemeyer basically over all his
research over Decades of
watching the market trading the market
understanding the market he sort of
settled on 70 of the volume gave the
optimal balance of relevance without
being too restrictive now the 70
represents the prices where the majority
of trading activity and Market agreement
is happening right people trade the
market not necessarily for speculation
the majority of big Traders they trade
it because you know they have a reason
right and the reason is you know
sometimes they need to hedge something
and you know or in the case of things
like Commodities you know they actually
need the underlying commodity and as a
result that generates support and
resistance right so knowing where the
majority of volume is trading right sort
of gives you balance in the market right
and
there is you know so sort of going back
to the question do I have a certain
percentage I like you know I stick with
um you know there are some purists out
there that think that 68 you know these
statisticians say well 68 is really the
uh the true measure
um that you should be using because you
know that represents sort of the the
mean and
um
one standard deviation on the other side
and when I talk about the mean it you
know volume tends to be normally
distributed distributed across prices in
liquid markets and the mean and one
standard deviation on other on either
side of that mean so it captures around
70 percent or they'll say 68 in a normal
distribution but I'm going to sort of
just show you there is generally minute
differences obviously if you're using 68
versus 70 so this is uh just really
quick this is a volume profile it's a 30
minute chart in E Minis
uh it's set at 70 percent you can see
right here value area percent and let's
just sort of compare them really quick
let's take a quick uh
screenshot here
and doesn't need to be too fancy and I'm
going to change it to uh 68 percent
okay now what there may be you know some
minute differences but overall it's
going to be about the same so this is
now set at 68 percent otherwise my uh
where's my Snapshot here it is it's on
this other screen let me just expand
this
a bit more so
this little
one here picturing a picture is 70 this
is 68 the big screen so you can see it's
still it's more or less about the same
um just really quick 43 89 43 89 43.99
spot 75 still the same 799 spot 75. uh
95 and a half 95 and a half oh five and
a quarter oh five and a quarter oh four
and three quarters oh four and three
quarters nine and a half
89 or 95 and a half now it's 89 and a
half 89 and a half
97 and a quarter here on the 68 chart
here it's 96 spot 75 so two tick
difference
um double o and a quarter double o and a
quarter
85 and a half here is showing 85.
90 and three quarters 90 and three
quarters so more or less it's the same
except you know you got here is a half
uh half a point two ticks and over here
is two tick difference now when you go
to smaller foreign
five minutes you are going to get more
difference because there's less volume
trading now what do I prefer I prefer 70
I think 70 is fine
um for me you know you if you're looking
at volume right you sort of want to grab
as much volume as possible and determine
where these value areas are so
you know for example right I have my
footprint chart
set to 70 percent
right here value area in percent and it
provides and to be honest if
most of the time right even if I was
using 68 percent
it's going to be a difference of like I
said one tick or maybe two ticks I'm
still looking at the exacts for the
exact same things right I'm looking for
those value areas that are not retested
in the next bar to see if they're going
to be retested right that's going to be
my support and resistance areas like
right here
right right here right I like to see how
the market comes back and trades into
these areas here right I see I know I
see my value area here
and we come back in I see some
aggressive buying come in that's what I
like to see when we test a value area
right here's a value where it's not
traded back into and let me just say
that when because that one of those
questions was what do I look for in
trading values I look for those
valuaries that is not retested
immediately by immediately I mean in the
next bar whether it's you know this is a
60-second chart basically a one minute
chart if I was looking at um do that but
if I was looking at a
five minute chart
look at the same things
the second to come up here it's Saturday
so
I'm recording this video so data is just
a little bit slow on Saturdays you know
I'm looking for those big value areas
that are not tested back into
right
here
here it's bullish right so I'm looking
for bullish if something like this right
this is a bearish value area it's a red
color that's why we color our value
areas
you don't need to but if I have this
value rate right if I'm looking at this
Market this one has me excited why
because I know value has been
overlapping here for one two three four
five bars even here six I'm not going to
chain these all together but more or
less it's right in here over these four
bars and I see this value area it's red
it's a bearish sign to me because it's
red right I see red I think the market
should go down but in this case the bar
closed above the value area it's a red
candle but we closed Above So In This
Bar it's actually rejecting value
then the next Bar opens we come just hit
the value area high one tick above
doesn't go inside that value area and
then it runs to the upside this is
actually a bullish
setup for me even though it's a red
candle down
the fact that we're closed above the
value area and we're trading above the
value area in the next bar and don't
trade back into it it sort of goes into
that bucket of what you expect to happen
doesn't happen but the opposite happens
that's your opportunity right everyone's
expecting it's sort of like oh you know
not to use a gambling reference but you
know sometimes you have such a big odds
on favorite
to win that the best bet is not to bet
the horse that's you know one to you
know odds on favorite one to twenty you
know you bet uh two dollars to win five
cents
what you got want to do is you want to
take a shot on those other horses in the
race that are 20 to 1 30 to 140 to 1.
because look how the market ripped up to
the upside right sometimes it's not the
clear obvious favorite that you expect
to
to win you know anything could happen in
a horse race right a horse could jockey
could fall off or something that's
happened on these horses that are odds
on but
it's what you're expecting right is that
green candle with the big value area
that's not retested in the next one and
for the market to rip right if you have
a red value area the market doesn't in
the Market's trading below it and we go
back up to test it and then we come off
again that's your trade to the downside
just as this one here is your trade to
the upside
okay and that's on a five minute chart
um if you're looking at
a 10 range chart now a 10 range chart
right on e-minis
you do get a bit more
in my opinion uh untested value areas
but again you know I'd still look at
them same just sort of go back here you
know when you start seeing untested
value area untested value area right you
know this trend is heading down
right just as untested value area
untested value where you start working
your way up that's your trade
okay
and you know with with
um
range based charts you tend to get a bit
more in my opinion abandoned valuaries
or value areas that aren't retested
right away
uh if you were to look at you know a
little volume we'll call it a 5000
volume chart
s
sort of the same thing okay and
let's just sort of give it a second come
up here
right here
here here
right bearish here bullish here
bullish here and again you know if it's
doesn't matter what Market you're
trading right say I was trading a
H gosh I don't know let's just pull up
Yen and
as well this is a 5000 volume chart I
wouldn't use a five thousand volume
chart on Japan but you can see the same
things I'm looking for those value areas
that aren't retested back into
right if I was using I don't know
a 100 tick chart
I don't know I'm just making that up
there but I'd still be looking for the
same thing the valuaries that aren't
traded back into here here
all right that's a hundred tick chart
you know even if I was on a five minute
chart on Japan
same thing I'd be looking for those
value areas and then again once it goes
back in and tests those I still want to
watch how the market reacts to it is it
accepting it or is it rejecting it
because if it's rejecting it I'm going
to look for the move away
and then what if I'm looking for the
rejection what am I looking at while I'm
looking at the order flow I'm looking at
the you know what the volume is taking
place there is there any uh Prominent
Point of controls what's the Delta doing
right we're testing it coming back in
here actually it's strong then it
weakens that's negative you know in this
case it just went sideways but I'm using
going through the steps of what I know
about order flow how I'm expecting the
market to react when it comes into value
just as as I would do it if the market
is coming into support or resistance or
coming into the high of the day or the
low of the day all right you're going to
be looking at the same things when
you're coming back into value
all right so I hope that uh clears up or
clears up but you know helps you
understand how I look at the value areas
in relation to order flow
so if you found this video helpful for
your understanding of water flow let me
know
you know put some comments below if it
if it needs some clarification and if
you haven't already be sure to subscribe
to the channel so thanks for watching
and being a part of my orophil community
you know your support is appreciated and
I'll see you guys on the next video bye
bye